one of the stars of the tournament one
of the stars of the upcoming draft the
former Murray State guard John Morant
joining us on the program good morning
John how are you I'm doing okay
who was your favorite NBA team growing
up I always liked whatever team my dad
liked and he was a big he's the rock
this band with the twin tiles of this I
grew up a chance for the Rockets did you
be played against NBA players before yes
it was a couple at the cp3 camp this
past summer so I got to play against
some of the young guys and also Chris
Paul how was that it was good really
taught me how to lead would be I would
offense ecology and everything so did he
transport you nah he didn't do too much
trash talking I also noticed that your
real name is Demetrius and jaws is a
shortened version of your your middle
name but are you in trouble when you
here to meet Ria's does you know if mom
says something or dad somebody in the
family that you have called their
poverty air jaws and your dad's name is
T now that's not short for Timmy Trias
isn't okay
when did you start beating your dad in
basketball so what how old were you when
you seen yeah I was like 15 16 somewhere
that Ray did you dunk on him it was a
video that he tried to tell me that he
was but he's got old man strength though
you always have to watch out for that
yeah and he made sure he used all his
files
he's got to be careful with how many
scholarship offers out of high school
I'm in was somewhere around 20 I may
start to come rolling in a little late
both really have to very stayed off that
AAU tournament like my last where you
turn was I received like I think 15 plus
officers and I wonder if you chose
Murray State because you know they were
they were loyal to you and then you know
I've sort of first in was that how you
were picking where you were going to go
to college I'm actually no I was really
just going to take bids a couple
colleges who was making sure they called
me almost every day and either talked to
my parents at Murray State was one of I
like that part about it they'll make him
making me seem like they wanted me so
when I said the visit I just fell in
love with the campus and everything the
people there they made me feel like I
was at home you were unranked with zero
stars by all major recruiting websites
coming out of high school
how's that possible John my parents just
hope you don't worry about rankings or
stars if there's somebody who's ranked
number one or have five stars and you
play against them they got to show you
that they're better than you so I just
took it like that and play with a chip
on my shoulder
who plays what's styled do you see
somebody in the NBA who plays like you
do you've been compared to anybody I
probably say who I try to play like this
where's Brooke he's my favorite player
and I just like sway all around you
score a rebound pass and also just
aggressiveness he plays with just like
he got a chip on his shoulder so what's
that gonna what's that gonna be like
that first time you step on the floor
and he got Westbrook just bringing it I
could tell you I would but it'll be just
me playing against my idol
so are you well I noticed like you
attack I think you're better shooter
than Westbrook at this age but you
attack the rim and you're fearless and
so I can see those comparisons with
Westbrook but you you actually go out of
your way or you're you bottled your game
after him so you wanted to be that kind
of player that you're displaying right
now yeah most people probably would
think so but I just feel like he's a
great player but just don't get respect
he deserves and I kind of felt like
that's how I was coming up I was a great
player but obviously was overlooked so
did you know Zion was going to be that
great when you're on the AAU team with
him I'm always new Zion was gonna be
great
honestly he was good and his 9th grade
year he was doing almost the same thing
but now he's just stronger and jump
higher so I always know he did drugs
I'll never dunk on you he happened I
made sure we was on the same team that's
very smart Jah see that's your see in
the court I I love that would you rather
score or have a great assistant I would
say he's just something I like to do
just share the ball and and that was
noticeable during the season and
certainly in the tournament like you got
great joy and you know and it's a credit
to Zion as well like you guys were
brought up well to understand how to
play basketball and appreciate the small
things and you had a past in the
tournament where you were more excited
than the person who scored on where did
that come from because most guys now you
know they want to just score yeah
honestly on my all go just taught me
like a poincare like world facilitator
I'm almost like I guess make plays for
him and also his teammates just to make
the job easier or his teammate so
imagine something I fell in love with I
just love going down
just to see their teammates have a smile
on a face or just help them build
confidence just feel good for the person
who passes them the ball so that's why I
enjoy these John Marant former Murray
State guard and probably going to hear
your name called pretty soon with that
NBA Draft would you would you have a
problem if a team passed you up to take
zion Williamson honestly I would means I
really have the same goal that is to put
the state of South Carolina on the map
we have a lot of talent down there but
we I guess we just overlooked so there's
just a goal for us and if the team pick
him over me I'd be happy for do you
think you're the best player in the
strength I really don't speak too much
on myself but your dad speaks about you
John your dad said after the
triple-double versus Marquette what he
did out here proves he's the best player
in the country when asked after the game
where you should go in the draft dad
said is there anything before number one
[Laughter]
joking type of guy but I don't think
he's joking I don't think he's joking I
think your dad feels like you're the
best player in the draft you should be
paying him he's your PR guy but that you
know that's strong stuff well you know
what I'm starting to hear more and more
JA is that people are you know we get
caught up in Zion he's a wonderful
player but you know playing in the NBA
and the style it might be suited more to
you and I've had guys who are in the NBA
played in the NBA or coached in the NBA
who said they would take you as the
number one pick overall so whether it
plays out that way
you're not gonna have to wait long
before you hear your name have you
picked out your outfit for the draft
night
am i having yet my actually probably I
start working on it this upcoming week
now here's the thing clean and
businesslike because 15 years from now
when they show you on draft night you
just don't want to have like a plaid red
suit or something like that so be be
business be all business when you're
there I'm a professional when it comes
to this job and I would just say I'm
gonna look clean I'm gonna look tight
and I'll have a little swag and I'm
gonna go up there and say Thank You
commissioner and I'm ready to go I'd
slap the floor I'd slap the floor before
I got up there like I'm ready to play
defense before I saw the Commissioner
what do you think hey good luck it was
fun watching you and look forward to
seeing you in the NBA okay
that's John Moran for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app